you're never
ever ever ever going to feel
like doing the things you need to do in
order
to have what you want you're always
going to need to push yourself
you're always going to need to parent
yourself
so what is the net advice on this what
what is the bottom line the bottom line
is
no one's coming no one
no one's coming to push you no one's
coming to tell you to turn the tv off
no one's coming to tell you to get out
the door and exercise
nobody's coming to tell you to apply for
that
job that you've always dreamt about
nobody's coming to write the business
plan for you
it's up to you and because you're only
ever going to do the things that you
feel
like doing right now or that feel good
right now
unless you understand that you've got to
parent yourself you got to push yourself
you're not going to make your dreams
come true you're just not
we're not wired that way you weren't
born that way you weren't that way when
you were growing up and you're certainly
not that way as an adult and there's a
tremendous amount of liberation that
comes when you accept the fact
that you're always going to need to give
yourself a push
i've always wanted a six-pack and i
don't have it
and i don't know and i've never had it
and
when i i finally stopped complaining
about it
when i got honest about what it was
going to require
oh i'm dead serious dead serious about
this at my
you know at 49 with my
affinity for alcohol and my love of
carbs
and my taste for exercise
i have a small problem on my hands if i
want a six-pack
so if you were to go forward right and
think okay well if a year from now i had
a six-pack
what would what would that actually what
would my day-to-day life look like
and you can get very clear that you're
not committed to that
and then you can stop beating yourself
up for the [ __ ] you never intend on
doing
what i realized is i can spend four
minutes a day in a hotel room or in my
bedroom doing planks and my arms look
great and everybody else will think the
rest of my body's in shape
we're good yes
it looks like a charm so you might want
to get honest with yourself
like instead of doing this i don't want
to be a millionaire
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
but you're gonna have to roll the clock
forward just a year and say okay
if i'm able to put
a thousand dollars a month against my
debt i'm able to
make x amount of dollars a month i'm
able to put x amount of dollars in
savings what do i need to be doing a
year from now to make that happen
and what are those habits that are there
a year from now
that i don't have right now and then
roll yourself back to this moment just
like i explained with exercise
do i actually not want to have a
manhattan tonight nope
did i want to go to the gym today nope
did i would am i am i willing to not eat
what i ate for
nope am i willing i did my four minutes
my arms are looking really good
but so bring it back and then you will
have the formula for pivoting
at any moment you time travel forward a
year
you investigate the patterns that you
have that are giving you the result that
you want and then you back your ass up
to right here right now
and you decide am i willing to do this
now
if i'm willing then five four three two
one through all the
excuses that are gonna be there when
you're trying to override your operating
system
that's how you do it or you have the
reality check like i had which is oh
[ __ ] i just like to [ __ ]
i don't intend on changing so why don't
we get this off the plate
and let's focus on the things that i am
actually committed to
in the ted talk i cited this this
statistic that i had read
uh years ago and that is that a
scientist had calculated the odds of you
and me being born
and when you think about just even the
sexual act of your parents in a lifetime
relationship the number of times they
would actually be intimate
the amount of sperm that go the the odds
of one egg and one sperm and then you
throw in
then you throw in the dna and the
uniqueness
of your dna structure
some scientists calculated all of those
odds and figured out that the odds of
you being you
who you are born the day that you were
born to the parents that you have
with the dna structure that you have
given
all the other variables that could have
changed something
the odds are one in 400 trillion that
you are you and so what that means to me
is that you're meant to be here that
there is a reason why you were born
and the journey of your life is to
figure it out
and i think it's actually simple i think
that
life is very simple and we complicate it
because we have brains that can tell
stories
and we have um bodies that can
sense danger and so we over
complicate things and the the purpose of
your life
is to listen to your heart and soul and
to follow it
and to express the highest version of
you
not the self-doubt not the anxiety not
the fears not the pettiness not the
frustrations but to actually have the
courage
to be fully expressed as
as like i it sounds stupid but you know
as the as a great human being to have
the courage to be kind to have the
courage to be patient to have the
courage to cheer for other people
and have the courage to tune in to that
wisdom that's inside of you
and lean into it follow the things that
pique your curiosity
do more of this that actually expands
your heart
and expands the amount of energy in your
body and slowly but surely if you align
all your decisions
and the things that you spend time on
and the people that you spend time on
with the things that naturally energize
you your whole life will experience a
shift
one of the most important things when
you're in a situation where the truth
the facts are
that there is more on your plate than
one human being can effectively handle
on his or her own there's a really
important
moment where you have to surrender to
the chaos
that your life is for the next couple
weeks
things are going to change when summer
hits but
part of what i find personally
is that when i resist and i do resist
i resist what's actually happening when
that's not
the way that i want things to go and so
if you
start complaining or you start bringing
extra weight to all of the things that
are going
on it's gonna make it feel even more
overwhelming
and if you can bring a sense of realism
to it so i
call this and i think sean anchor's the
one that came up with this
this this term realistic
optimism realistic optimism
is a really powerful mindset because
you're not just putting a sunny spin on
a crappy situation
you're being realistic about where you
are in your life
right now and you are
still maintaining an
optimistic point of view and
what that means is that you when you're
an
optimist you believe that your actions
and your thoughts matter
you believe that you can handle what's
on your plate you believe
that based on your thoughts and your
actions you
can positively affect the outcome of
whatever it is that you're dealing with
whether it's being wildly overwhelmed
because you're a single parent
or terrified because you just got a
scary health diagnosis
or you're spinning because somebody just
told you they don't want to be in a
relationship with you anymore
whatever it is that you're facing that's
making you feel overwhelmed
first start with how important it is to
be
a realistic optimist so there's a
surrendering to what's so but you're
going to stay
very optimistic and positive and know
that everything that you think and do is
in your control
and that when you know that your
behavior matters
it gives you a sense of empowerment
that's proven by research
super duper important it's also why
you can have a very hard life right now
and a very
overwhelming life right now and still be
happy
because you know based on being a
realistic
optimist that this period will pass
and you know that there are things that
you can think about and do that are
within your control
you know that um wave that you feel or
your tongue gets numb or you get
tightness in your cheeks
or you freeze you know when that happens
based on the science there is only a
90-second
chemical release in your body it's
called the 90-second rule
when your body starts to stomach starts
to flutter when your heart starts to
race when you feel this feeling of fear
that you have that's unique to you
based on the science there's a 90-second
rule and
all of the chemical release that's
happening because your body is going
into a state of being alert
it only sticks around for 90 seconds
as long as you don't let your thoughts
race if your thoughts start to race
you'll start to agitate the situation
the next time that your body
goes into a state of alert stomach gets
tight you feel frozen
you get stuck you feel your neck when
the body starts to do that
number one just remember
it means your body is getting ready to
be alert and pay attention doesn't and
it does not mean you're going to lose
control
it does not mean you're in danger it
does not mean to stop or to shut up
i want you to take a deep breath
count to five five four three two one
that's it
and realize that the hormones that just
got released
because you're about to do something
they only last 90 seconds that's it
you can breathe slowly you can count to
90. you can get up and walk around you
can do 90 seconds of jumping jacks
you can meditate for 90 seconds you can
ground your feet in your chair
and wiggle a minute so that you feel
your body in your chair
and take deep breaths and what you're
going to
find is that you're going to be blown
away
you're going to be blown away because
what you're going to see is that
in 90 seconds flat you can go from being
somebody
who has an upset stomach and who would
normally not go talk to your boss who
would
normally not walk into that gym who
would normally
not make that call in 90 seconds flat
you can manipulate your body state to
calm down
and you will notice that your thoughts
do not race your thoughts calm down
you're in full control and now you can
speak up and now you can show up
the most important thing hang out with
people that cheer for you
this is so important i don't like i
can't say this enough
behavior is contagious they have proven
this
they have proven this google the
framingham study it was a really famous
heart study that was done where they
looked at human behavior
over what's called a longitudinal study
which basically means they studied
people for a number of years
and they found that you catch the
behavior of other people if you hang out
with smokers over time your objection to
smoking lowers because you're hanging
out with smokers and you become
socialized to it
and you are more likely to smoke if you
hang out with happier people if you hang
out with people that are more successful
than you if you hang out with people
that
run all the time guess what happens you
become socialized
to those positive behaviors the fastest
way to make a behavior change
is to hang out with people that are
positive that are cheering for you that
are up to cool stuff
that are so busy and engaged in their
life they don't have time for passive
aggressive [ __ ]
because they're busy building something
and being appreciative
and that's who you should hang out with
here's your new definition of passion
passion is simply energy
that's all that it is okay passion
is what you feel when you are energized
and excited about what you're doing
okay i want you to think about that for
a minute i want you to think about a
moment in time
when you felt incredibly passionate
about something
okay and why don't you in the comments
tell me where are you watching from
and tell me about a moment in time when
you felt incredibly
passionate about what you were doing
about where you were about the people
that you are with describe
that moment for me because when you
start to
really investigate passion as energy
this is what you're going to discover
those moments when you were super
passionate like i'm sure my kids would
write down when they're doing community
theater with all their friends
i would write down whenever i'm doing
any kind of creative project with my
team
i'm incredibly energized whenever i'm
doing
group exercise stuff climbing a mountain
uh doing a 5k race doing some sort of
walkathon
i'm incredibly energized by that
whenever
i'm um doing some sort of creative
project
incredibly energized by that whenever
i'm working with our video team
incredibly energized by that whenever
i am coaching someone or giving advice i
am
incredibly energized by that and so what
i want you to understand is that if you
look back on your life you have had
moments where you have felt passion
i'm being very deliberate now i'm
talking this morning on coffee talk
because
passion is a huge topic for so many of
you
and you've been so focused on trying to
figure out what job is going to make me
passionate what job is my passion what
is my purpose on the earth
i'm going to tell you what your purpose
on earth is right now your purpose
on earth is to figure out how to align
your life
so that you feel more energized and
excited by it
that's it and it begins with you
following the energy and following your
natural enthusiasm
you're not going to think your way to
passion you can't think your way to
finding something that you feel in your
heart it doesn't work that way
you got to feel your way into it it's
inside of you do you understand
there's no passion out there somewhere
the passion is in here
and so what you have to do first is
you've got to stop thinking
that you're going to find it somewhere
and you've got to realize that passion
is about
unlocking something that's already in
you today
for the next 24 hours i want you to
assume
that everybody else around you has the
best intentions
the person that cuts you off in traffic
the friend that's not texting you back
the customer that writes an email that
has a snarky tone
whatever it may be the fact that you may
be riled that you posted something on
facebook and
and one of your best friends didn't tag
you in it or didn't like
it i mean we get hung up around the
stupidest stuff
but today i want you to assume the best
intentions you know this recently
happened to me where i really had to put
this to use
i had a situation at work where i had a
conference call and it was related to a
speech
and it was one of these kind of kickoff
calls where a bunch of people on the
client side are going to be there and
we're going to talk about the event and
i'm going to talk about the speech and
during the conversation this conference
call i
said something that i didn't mean to say
i was totally responsible i basically
said
what day am i speaking now i knew the
date that i was speaking
what i didn't know is in the flow of the
event
was i the opener was i the closer was i
the person that's supposed to be the
defibrillator after a big lunch like
what role
am i playing that's a really important
thing to understand if you're giving a
speech because it helps you customize
what you're going to do
well the client misunderstood me because
i wasn't precise
and they were annoyed because they
thought holy cow we've we've hired this
person we've sent her all kinds of
information she doesn't even know what
day she's speaking
so the client gets upset they complain
to the event planner
the event planner then writes me one of
these emails that's like this long
the planner was really upset because i
had made
the planner look bad in front of the
client
now fully my responsibility completely
unintentional
and also based on a gigantic
misunderstanding so what did i do well i
did exactly
what you should do when you screw up i
took total responsibility i apologized i
went overboard and
cleaned the mess up i wrote a long email
i actually left voicemail messages
when we had to deliver a bunch of things
i went overboard and being great about
it and you know what i got from
the planner that was really upset with
me nothing
i didn't get an email back i didn't get
a phone call back
even though i had requested one nothing
nothing nothing nothing and of course
what happens when somebody
doesn't respond to you whether it's
somebody that you're dating or it's
somebody that's a good friend
or it's a customer or somebody that's
upset with you and you've apologized
you immediately think that you've done
something wrong
we even do it if you get an email and
somebody's tone is slightly off it is
bananas how quickly we assume male
intent we assume we're in trouble we
assume
we've done something wrong so what did i
do in this situation
because my reaction was i was
disappointed that i didn't
actually get a nice email back or hey no
problem let's move on and have a great
event just got silenced what did i do
i use the five second rule 54321 when i
catch myself thinking about it and then
i assume positive intent
i tell myself a different story i say oh
well i've apologized twice so maybe the
planner feels
that everything is complete and taken
care of and no need to discuss it
further i also assume hey
this event is a big event i'm sure
they're super duper busy and this is the
last concern on their list another thing
that you can say is
maybe they're busy maybe this isn't a
big deal to them
maybe i've already been forgiven the
businesses that were launched by
somebody like
you who was working full-time while
launching your business
had a 33 percent less
chance of failing than the people that
quit their jobs and jump all
in and the reason why is you know how to
hedge your bets
you're a little conservative in terms of
the risks that you'll take
which means over the long term your
business is more likely to succeed
you asked me how do i balance my
passions how do you find the time
because i like you have a million things
going on
from being an on-air commentator to cnn
to having an incredible partnership with
success magazine and doing a ton of cool
stuff with them
to giving over 80 speeches a year and
running a company
and having a family the key is this
you must find 30 minutes before 7
30 in the morning 30 minutes before 7
30 that you take it home that you take
at a coffee shop
where you organize your day and you work
on two things that will push your
business
forward 30 minutes before 7 30.
why do you need to do this well because
when you walk into work your day is
likely going to get hijacked
and secondly if you were to take this
time
every single morning and focus yourself
you're now
starting your day having already done
work to advance your business
and you're walking into your current job
knowing what you need to get done that's
going to make you work
smarter at work i think a lot of people
that are
working a job full-time and also trying
to launch a business on the side
actually have the time the problem is
that you're not
being rigorous and focused about what
you're spending it on
if you want another mel robbins
affirmations for success video
check it out right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there if you expect to
achieve your goals if you expect to
reach your potential if you expect to
have your dreams come true